[Música]
y llegamos a directo hasta reino unido-
a londres específicamente la capital de
ese país es para hablar entender un poco
digamos esta carrera de cara al 10 de
downing street tras la renuncia del
primer ministro boris johnson vamos
entonces a conversar con nuestra
corresponsal marcela gutiérrez y
preguntarle en qué difieren las posturas
de resisten a clijsters ellos son por
supuesto los dos o candidatos finalistas
esto en lo referente a la política
fiscal además porque este tema fue el
eje central de este primer debate
televisado el día de ayer
crisis una que listo se están tratando
de distanciarse en cuanto a la política
fiscal por ejemplo el que fue hasta hace
tres semanas ministro de hacienda de
richi zona que asegura que no va a bajar
los impuestos hasta que se estabilice la
inflación y recordemos que la inflación
es la más alta que ha tenido el reino
unido en los últimos 40 años sin embargo
listos asegura que bajará la carga
tributaria desde el primer día si es que
llega a la oficina del número 10 de
downing street y este tema es muy
importante para el electorado porque en
el reino unido- la población está
sufriendo el alto costo de vida
provocada por el aumento en los
energéticos y también en los alimentos
así que ambos candidatos están tratando
de convencer a sus bases del partido
conservador que tienen según cada uno de
ellos la mejor política fiscal y el
mejor manejo de la economía en este
debate se pudieron distanciar el uno del
otro y también mostrar sus diferentes
personalidades y diferentes políticas en
cuanto a la economía y también en cuanto
a la política fiscal
así de marcela le pregunté entonces cuál
de los aspirantes parece el más
opcionado a convertirse en el próximo
primer ministro de reino unido
la ministra de relaciones exteriores se
está perfilando como la favorita para
suceder a boris johnson en esta carrera
como primer ministro de ser así y de
resultar electas sería la tercera mujer
en llegar a este puesto al número 10 de
downing street después de margaret
thatcher y theresa may así que esta
carrera es altamente competitiva sin
embargo es una que en algunos de los
sondeos de opinión rápidos de esta
mañana aparece como el ganador del
debate televisivo de anoche pero serán
los 160.000 miembros del partido
conservador quienes tengan la última
palabra ya que ambos candidatos los
finalistas en esta contienda tendrán que
convencer a los miembros del partido
conservador para que voten por ellos
a nivel nacional habrá varios eventos
antes de que se defina un ganador el
próximo 5 de septiembre